Health care is hugely inefficient
industry Mckinsey analyze the American
healthcare system versus healthcare
systems in the other country and it came
up with a figure that there is about a
half a trillion dollars of.
I would put it waste in the US
healthcare system.
The biggest source of waste is the way
we treat people with chronic diseases.
Diseases like diabetes,
AIDS,
heart disease,
cancer,
people who have chronic disabilities
like bad backs,
and we treat them in a very fragmented
way.
We have no one organization that is
responsible for everything that the
person with diabetes has.
Everything that the person with AIDS
needs,
needs.
People have tremendously complicated
needs there in diseases core
multifactorial,
and they manifest themselves in many
different ways.
What we need as a healthcare system
that's organized around the needs of the
patient for total care for their
diseases,
total care for their disability.
What we have as a healthcare system
that's organized by inputs,
doctors,
hospitals,
nursing homes,
each one of these inputs,
each one of these providers,
what did they want?
Well,
they hilman.
What they want is they want to make sure
that they met summize,
their share of their pie.
Maximizing their share of the pie is not
the same as doing what's best for that
patient.